I have to ask that we I I feel like we
have to have some similar interest like
vocally growing up like musically like
what were your influences um okay so a
lot of Fleetwood Mac I mean Stephen Nick
I I like have the Husky raspy yes Bonnie
yes Bonnie R you can belt like you know
that like big voice sound right and
growing up I just couldn't get enough
Fleetwood Mac um and then come on Seline
Deion oh my God Whitney yeah Ara so much
artha I remember my uh my my aunt she
would always play like Al Green artha
all the mot toown my dad was like heart
he loved he was obsessed with anything
that was classic rock so he would act
when we were kids he would put this the
radio on and he'd say all right here's
the deal this is like the best way for a
parent if they want to like only listen
to what they want to listen to pay your
children tell me pay your children so
this is what he would do he' say here's
the deal we're going to play this game
called the do game now it was actually
really helpful looking back because it
trained my ear but he would say if you
could guess who's singing the song then
I'll give you a dollar if it's really
hard I'll give you $5 yeah he got to
listen to whatever he wanted meanwhile
I'm I'm making some cash right so I'm
like I want to know I want to know what
what song and it was training my ear and
I didn't come from a musical family like
I I know I just found so much joy and
passion and and money
yeah and I got paid love that meanwhile
my mom was like can you not sing so loud
in the car like probably cuz I was
trying to I was always trying I love the
background Parts when I was a kid like
learning all I was like what's happening
there I found that so interesting did
you start harmonies when you were young
yes I I will I don't think I was good at
it which is why my mother wanted me to
shut up but I I think that's why I you
know I put in the work in the car every
time we were in the car we always listen
to the radio she loves music nobody like
really saying in my family like to the
extent of like what we do but like I
they love music like everybody did but I
want to give you a pop quiz cuz your dad
if he trained you well I want to give
you Jason you got a pup quiz for
[Music]
Lauren oh
Angel
[Music]
Wass where they L yeah that's what song
is that
about wait hold up wait for it
come to Kelly you don't make look at
here Dad it's
$55 you get it you get a bonus cuz you
made
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home